[Music]
hey what's up y'all man thank you all
for tuning in to another episode of
flatline with your boy david lucas here
live from the thick boy studios and
y'all have been coming with that
straight fire all week man like y'all is
ain't nobody hurt my feelings yet but
y'all cooking bro the heat y'all turn it
up a little nice man y'all turn up one
more knots
i'm gonna read some of my favorites that
i saw in the youtube comments and the
rest of my team thought it was pretty
funny but let's get into it man
david looks like he plays spades with
pokemon cards
that's that
i might
david's parents debated on naming him
pork chop
i mean that comes from one of my
favorite shows as a kid because i if
y'all know doug funny his dog was named
pork chop
david looks like he had an older sister
to protect him growing up
david likes fishing because there's
nothing better than a free buffet you
know what bro i come from the country
and we actually do we kind of like eat
what we kill so yeah i can i can see
where you're cooking
david's got the breathing patterns of a
french bulldog
[ __ ] y'all all right man we're gonna get
into some topics this week
we're gonna start with some uh some la
news if you follow my instagram you have
definitely seen this on my instagram but
la
has a homeless problem and it looks like
uh ashley larry aka donnell rollins got
kicked off of the dave chappelle tour so
now he's breaking into cars roll the
club mike
hey [ __ ]
gotcha
that's danielle ryland's [ __ ]
got your [ __ ] gotcha
come on
come on [ __ ]
this guy has stole danielle rollins
throat
that's not really done that rollins but
it's fun to make fun of doughnut rollins
man come on man
that is ashley larry
everybody knows that's actually larry
and speaking of crackheads and the
homeless population
the biden administration has took i
believe
is it 30 million dollars out of our
tax-paying funds
and he's gonna now start handing out
crack pipes
to drug addicts because they say this
will limit infections amongst drug users
when did we give a [ __ ]
about anybody that smoke crack
when
i'll wait
now we care if a crackhead gets an
infection
really like crack is not one of those
drugs where you need to be clean or the
pipe needs to be cleaned to smoke it
you're smoking drano
ajax and embalming fluid i don't know
that's i don't know that's the
ingredients of crack but it sounds
pretty accurate but who gives a [ __ ] has
a crackhead ever said i'm not gonna
smoke crack because my crack pipe ain't
clean and sanitary
hell no man biting you on some [ __ ]
but y'all voted him in i didn't
this is y'all's president
all right man
we're gonna go ahead and get into it bro
uh i feel like i'm gonna get
some good jokes this week
we'll see what y'all got for me man
let's do it
long your face look like kevin durant
foot [ __ ] get your little stupid ass
everybody here
i
know your face look like a sandwich from
jersey mike
you guys see my type profile though do
you want rosemary or italian bread face
head why get your little stupid ass
somebody here
the bread stick face say i'm ready to
dip your face in some olive oil a bit
can you hear me can you hear me yeah i
can hear your little goofy boy
they give unlimited of your faces at
olive garden
unlimited hell yeah unlimited bread
sticks and salad face
[Laughter]
what's up bro how you doing well your
face looked like a chuck taylor bit
[Laughter]
bro have you seen that my side my side
profile though no [ __ ] that bro your
face look like one of them bones they'll
find and be like this bone is 30 000
years old
your face was an archaeologist
experiment
[Laughter]
your face looked like the first tibula
they
found how are you so fast how's your
brain working i don't know dog
what's uh what's a ram in your brain
judging by the lethal your face take a
lot for a thought to come from here
from here
that bigger brain is socially distanced
from his mouth bit i can see why i take
you a minute
i didn't know this right that [ __ ] was
like 101. your brain told your mouth to
give me
[Laughter]
what's up man what are you drinking
nothing i'm drinking long face [ __ ]
[Laughter]
no faith is longer than a work day with
overtime bit
damn i didn't know this was that long
your face looked like one of elon musk's
rocket ships
oh dildo face ass [ __ ]
you had to get that face from a sex shop
bro okay can you rap are you a good
rapper no [ __ ] but you can eat 12
[ __ ] out at one time with that long
ass face
[Laughter]
like a real ariel stein [ __ ]
what up david ate all the lucas hey bro
get your get yo
get your little 1980s run jeremy looking
at somebody here what
hey how many looks does it actually take
to get to the city roll to throw just to
pop why your ass look like ron jeremy
and danny devito at the same time your
ass stupid as [ __ ] boy
those are daddies your ass look like you
read tarot cards to tell you what to
have for dinner
the man on the bicycle means burger
you know the nene by heart already bro
you look like you got a house full of
parrots [ __ ] like you just collect
exotic birds [ __ ] i don't know
why
i got to put them in the road so you can
eat them
you go to your house you go to your
house you look like you're cooking [ __ ]
toucan scrambled egg
whatever you want baby i know you got it
you look like you do the running of the
bulls i don't know why bro but you look
like you knew that [ __ ]
and you'll be there for the barbecue
when they catch it and why your glass is
so thick you got bulletproof windows on
your face
i'm in houston man
your glasses can take a sniper
rifle you gotta use one to catch your
dinner sometimes wait that boy got fog
proof shatterproof glasses why get your
dumb ass about it
love you you know you bought them
[ __ ] off a commercial you can step on
them drop them and even scratch them
ain't got a prescription and a music
yeah yeah
thick with three seeds like big boy
hey what's up bro you look like you got
a hard dick when you heard rogan say the
n word 30 times
jesus christ
that's going to make this next joke so
much worse
[Laughter]
david your lips are so big when you talk
[ __ ] too fast the climate changes
that's our best roaster bro
it's our best roaster broth
i got a whole lot of love for you today
let's hear it
all right last week you said i look like
i got 20 confirmed kills in iraq you
look like you have 20 confirmed
abortions in
[Laughter]
crime georgia with the heat let's hear
it boys yeah i got it
all right you call plus-sized chicks fat
[ __ ] but it seems like you should be
calling me size chicks
just made you crave chick-fil-a hey krom
you look like your guilty pleasure is
sticking your balls in a bear trap
[Laughter]
yeah man i just realized all your jokes
about eating chicks out are all inspired
by the chick-fil-a drive-thru
all right this one all right
david i'm going to get with all your
baby mamas just so they know what it's
like to be with a thick boy that can
last longer than 10 minutes without them
having to use a defibrillator
[Music]
oh no not again boom
hey chrome you look like you blow into a
crown you look like you blow into a duck
call before you get your dicks up
you look like you gave your girlfriend
fishing lures for earrings for
valentine's day [ __ ]
hey baby put this treble hook in your
[ __ ] here
hell yeah boy if you don't get
all right
you look like your nickname for your
dick is a trick rubber worm that's a
fishing reference
when krong pulls his dick out he says
baby this is carolina rigg
only fishing people go goddamn only fish
people get that joke man [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you get it kron you fish
all right i got one more and it's a
twofer
david how are you going to talk [ __ ] for
a living when he lost a wrestling match
to 120 pound dude that's built for
taking for playing golf and taking dick
i'm glad a lot of people don't know that
reference so we're going to cut that
[ __ ] out
[Laughter]
i ain't crying bro you know it's always
dope the roasted juice dawg thank you
and keep hitting me every week bro cause
you you come with the fire bruh you come
with that [ __ ]
i come with it love you brother take
care
how's it going how's it going david yeah
bro
where you calling from dog you're in
front of a [ __ ] ass tilt fallout
shelter
i'm i'm from the bay area man i saw you
recently in san jose man you're [ __ ]
awesome brother freaking awesome you
gotta you got an uh a patch you got an
apache uh medicine doctor jacket on
all right it's nice you have a sumo
[ __ ] haircut right now it's [ __ ]
like
you about to take some ginger root some
tumeric and cure cancer
yes
damn man i never thought you guys would
uh get me on but i think the one thing
that i said is that you look like uh you
look like you have lizzo's body in the
face of an amazon driver and you look
like a peruvian drill sergeant
bro you look like a you look like an
educated sea turtle with the [ __ ]
glasses
hell nah
oh sophisticated ass sea turtle
looking [ __ ]
you you don't only see turtle don't eat
kelp
they only eat plankton
[Laughter]
why did you have to do the the hair back
man you made your hand like double the
size today because i got hair unlike you
bro
i got a [ __ ] up haircut but you like
you can you can cap on that one right
there stupid as a [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i did it myself it's my own carpentry
brother you you ordered it you ordered
that
you ordered that haircut at an ice cream
shop
that's a [ __ ] chocolate swirl bruh
yeah alan up in this [ __ ] looking like
the employee at netflix that quit over
dave chappelle special
you look like you get your haircuts at
the liquor store
what is what is this guy smoking all bro
i say something
david lucas get hungry and his cr his
stomach's in christmas carols
bro you look like you got sent back to
mexico for stealing 200 worth of bananas
oh [ __ ]
um
god damn it
i ain't got nothing yo mama do all her
christmas shopping at the grocery store
y'all get weird [ __ ] for christmas like
a a box of oranges
a box of words
i heard your sister got some shell
pecans for christmas one year
sorry i don't even know her sister
well you got one now
i gave you one [ __ ] hey
how you gonna be a venezuelan
hey bro your haircut is about to ask for
the manager
god damn you again bro what up but me
again the brazilian terrace is back
what's up it's a ladder that [ __ ] is
over over there stealing bread you got a
pet monkey
you know how you make a carpet fly you
look like you can make a bathroom fly
[ __ ] get your little dirt oh yeah wait
where do you get yo bro where you get
where you getting your teeth from man
bojack horseman man
[Laughter]
huh
you big in oz xl
bro i do not speak middle eastern
big
xl it doesn't work anymore it's fine
you can't use google translate to
translate your jokes because
uh
english my connect
why you got your little hair in the butt
man you look good as [ __ ] little
bunny right there
man i took my hair out dawg
look at that turn your hair out
your ceilings little bro you must be in
one of uh osama bin laden's hideout
shelters
yeah that's right
i was loved wait five foot [ __ ] little
boy
i'm just tall let's say i'm fine that
boy is on al jazeera tv right now
[Laughter]
that boy using that
wi-fi network
[Laughter]
i got out here
hey man thank you for everybody that
brought that fire ass energy man y'all
brought them jokes y'all prepared y'all
came ready that's what the [ __ ] i like
man like come ready come prepared hit me
hurt my feelings that's what i want
somebody to hurt my feelings i want to
call my mama after this show
all right man i'll see y'all next week
and make sure you comment in the youtube
i want to see it man and maybe your joke
will be on the following week boom we
outta here
dick boy studios baby
you